-Thank you so much
for coming on
and especially around this --
this time of year.
-Hi, everyone.
-Yeah, I want to get into
all the Halloween stuff that
you -- I know you love doing.
-My Halloween shenanigans.
-Yes, but I want to --
There's so many things
I want to talk to you about.
"America's Got Talent:
Fantasy League."
-Yes.
-What is it?
How do we
explain it to everybody?
-So, "Fantasy League,"
this is like a new spin-off show
that we do of
"America's Got Talent."
So this time around,
Mel B is back,
which I'm excited
to see Mel again.
-Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And obviously Simon Cowell,
Howie Mandel, Terry Crews.
But for this time around, we get
to, like, have our own team.
So how we got about this
was very funny
because you had to have
a long straw,
medium straw or shorter straw,
shortest straw,
and whoever pulls the longest
straw gets to choose first.
Guess who picked
the longest straw.
-Yeah!
-I did. So that was amazing.
So I bolted for everyone
who I loved.
Guess who had
the shortest stick.
-Simon?
-It was Simon.
[ Laughter ]
I was so excited.
So he was always last
to draw your favorite act.
So everyone has 10 acts,
and then we get to mentor them
and help them, hopefully
make their act even better.
-It's like a little
extra stuff in the line. Yeah.
-So I was like, "Okay.
What are we getting?"
Because, you know,
they get $250,000.
And they were like,
"Well, nothing."
And I'm like, "No, we need
to have something."
Like, at least we have to have,
like, a little...
-A trophy or something.
-I'm sure a trophy or something,
but I'm sure that Simon
is making, like,
a bobblehead doll of himself
or something like that.
-How is your --
How is your team?
-My team is the best team!
I mean, I can't tell you
who's on the team.
You have to watch and see it.
But, you know, America got
to vote on who they want,
you know, those acts to be.
-So it's the best.
-So we had all of these acts
to choose from.
But I had the longest stick,
so I got --
I feel like
I have the best one.
-Yeah, I hear you.
Yeah.
You're gonna win.
You have good taste.
-It's a lot of fun.
-You have good taste.
Earlier this week, though,
you were taping,
and something happened on set,
and you had a mishap, and you
brought us exclusive footage
and wanted everyone to see.
Take a look at what happened
on set. This is Heidi Klum.
-Hi!
Oh!
[ Audience gasps ]
[ Heidi laughs ]
[ Music stops ]
-Are you okay?
-Yeah.
-Hi.
-That was a fall.
-Are you okay?
-Yes. I just --[ Laughs ]
-You nearly pulled me down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-That's a fall.
Oh, my God!
-I know. Did you hear Mel?
-She was like,
"You almost pulled me down."
She told me that four times.
Simon just leaned over to me,
and he's like, "Make more --
Make more of it.
Make more of it."
[ Laughter ]
-Make it -- He's like,
"Are you okay?" "Yeah."
"Make more of it.
Make a TV show."
-But it's so funny,
the schadenfreude that happens.
You know, the word, like, when
someone falls it's like --
everyone was like, "Aah!"
It was just funny.
-Everything went silent.
But then look at this, though.
Your leg started bleeding.
-I mean, it literally
looks like a cat scratch,
but it was deep.
Someone had to come
and glue it shut.
Have you ever had
something glued shut?
[ Laughter ]
-Why are you looking up?
-No. [ Stammers ]
No.
-It's amazing.
They put this superglue
in your wound, and it just ckk!
-And that's instead of stitches.
-With, like, a little
butterfly thing on it.
-But Heidi Klum --
Heidi Klum's legs are like,
you're like --
this is like Lloyds of London.
I mean, this is insured by --
Oh, you hurt your arm, too?
-Yeah.
I mean, honestly,
it looked funnier than it --
-You can't do this
to Heidi Klum. This is --
I know you're not American,
but you are an American --
Yeah, you are.
-I am.
What are you talking about?
I've been here longer
than I have been in Germany.
I have an American passport.
Ja.
-Yeah, "Ja."
[ Laughter ]
-Ja.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-I want to say happy birthday,
by the way.
-50, yes.
That was fun. It still is.
-There's you and Sofía Vergara.
-Ha!
-Oh, I love her, too.
-I love her.
No, this was --
My husband, you know, he's like,
"Should we do a surprise party?"
And I'm like, "Well,
there goes the surprise."
-"You can't tell me.
You can't tell me you're
throwing me a surprise party."
-Yeah.
-That's the whole
surprise of it, yeah.
-I would love one because,
you know, otherwise, every year
is just another year,
and you get older and older.
But I thought, "50?"
I'm like, "Yes, go for it.
Make a big party."
And so we had, like,
a big, like, '20s-themed party.
It was a lot of fun.
-Happy happy birthday.
How is your husband, by the way?
-Hold are you now?
-I'm 49.
-Ah, so you're not there yet.
Almost.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-How old do I --
How old do I look?
-49.
[ Laughter ]
But, also, I have --
I can't see well.
I can only see far.
Like, this is, like -- yeah.
It's all, like, very --
looks very good, yeah.
-I'm gonna go all out for 50
and do something.
-Like, my husband, because you
were talking about my husband,
my husband, you know,
he is doing --
-He's the host of
"That's My Jam" in Germany.
-"That's My Jam" in Germany.
And they just won, basically,
the Emmy of Germany
for "That's My Jam."
-Yeah. He's the best.
Give him my best.
He's so funny.
Really talented.
I love him.
Give him my best, please.
And tell him congratulations.
-I will.
-Halloween, it's a big deal.
You love Halloween.
-For me, the biggest deal.
-Why, though?
-I don't know. Because
I'm obsessed with Halloween,
and I'm obsessed --
Yeah, Questlove is laughing
because Questlove --
thank you so much --
for years and years
and years and years,
he always comes to my party,
and he makes sure
that we all have the best time.
-He's the best.
He D.J.'s your parties.
-The music, the best.
And sometimes he literally
stays the end with me
until they swoop us out.
They're like,
"Can you please go home now?"
-He's a great guy
to have at a party.
But your Halloween costumes
are next level.
Next level.
-Yeah, I love it.
Because I love
the fantasy of it all.
I love the fantasy.
I love becoming someone else
for people to guess.
Last year, I was a cute
little rain worm and...
-You want to see
the cute little rain worm?
-Yeah, I was a cute
little rain worm.
-Look how frightening
is this thing. Oh, my God.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Yeah.
Can we talk about
this back bend that I --
Yeah, that was
a good back bend, yeah.
-No, this was very hard.
I was very claustrophobic
because basically they had
to tie my arms down
in order to be in this position.
And then my face was, like,
glued to the outside of it,
so I couldn't really move
my face any which way.
I was just stuck.
So three hours beforehand,
I wouldn't eat anymore.
I wouldn't drink anything
because, I mean,
I could have worn a diaper,
I guess, in there, but I didn't.
-What are you talking about?
No, you're not wearing a...
-I also could've just let it go.
No one would have known.
-We have a video of you
and Quest, I think,
from last year's party.
-It's always the best.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What is going on?
How are you acting --
[ Cheers and applause ]
First of all, how are you acting
like that's normal,
like that's not happening
behind you?
There's a dancing worm
behind you.
I -- You know, I just...
-Yeah, exactly.
-He's always the best
because I never tell anyone.
So the first reaction
when you see me,
you're always like me, "Neh."
-Yeah.
You know what I think --
Of course you do so many things.
You're so busy.
But I think you should host,
like, a -- like, a
Halloween special for NBC.
-I want to.
I would love to, yeah.
-You should do it
like New Year's Eve or...
Yeah, where people
get to dress up.
-Yes! And you got bands, and you
have a whole super party.
-Yeah.
-You would do that?
-Yeah, I would love it.
-See? That's --
-Just I'm throwing out
ideas for you.
What -- Can we see what
you're going to be?
-I had this idea
before, obviously.
-No.
-You never said it on
national television before.
-Well, you did.
-Yeah. Here we go.
And so next year,
the inaugural Heidi-Ween.
-Ooh, yes.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
See? They like the name.
-Yes.
-I came up with the --
I came up with the name, too.
What -- Can you hint at what
you're going to be this year?
-No, because, you know, I always
like it for it to be a surprise.
Otherwise, people are like,
"Oh, she's gonna be this,"
and then I show up,
and they're like,
"Eh, it wasn't as good as I
thought she was gonna do."
So I always think it's never
good to talk about it.
-Okay.
-But it's gonna be gigantic.
And I have to close a few
streets down here in Manhattan,
which is very hard to do,
by the way.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-Wait. So it's a giant costume?
You have to close streets down?
-Yeah.
-Are you a Transformer?
Like, an 18-wheeler?
-It's really.
-Are you like a robot?
A giant truck robot
that transforms.
-It's really big.
-I guessed it.
-No, you didn't.
-Yeah, I did.
-I swear.
-No, I know it, I know it.
Now you have to change
your costume.
[ Laughter ]
I love it.
-I swear, I'm not.
-I love it when you
come on the show,
and I cannot wait to see what
you're gonna do this year.
You're always the best.
Heidi Klum, everybody.
"America's Got Talent:
Fantasy League"
premieres in January on NBC.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around everybody.